what would you say is the one paragraph
thesis of killing the deep state one
paragraph would be that the holdovers
from the Obama administration and CIA
and the Justice Department and the FBI I
have formed a coup d'état attempt to
make sure the Donald Trump never
continues to serve as president uh and
then the other sentence I'd add to that
is that the book is about the steps that
Donald Trump must take is the process of
taking in order to preserve the
Constitution and and what I allege is
basically treason you know I heard some
of these phrases bandied about in the
past couple of years and I really didn't
attach a lot of meaning to them until
maybe more recently so maybe you can
define in your view or the deep state a
shadow government and the swamp the same
thing or how would you differentiate
between those well of course these these
are terms that are loosely used I mean
people do loosely use them and they have
different meanings but they all
essentially come down to the same
concept and that is that there's in
Washington a group of entrenched
interests that are represented in the
bureaucracy and I largely take the
intelligence agencies than Justice
Department certainly the IRS but also
other agencies that are on their own
agenda and the agenda is really an
internationalist agenda increasingly the
people hired in the bureaucracy have
been on new world order types they
believe in globalism they tend to see
the United States is archaic is outmoded
that we need to redefine the
Constitution many of these people in the
entrenched bureaucracy come out of the
universities and are fairly relatively
young anywhere from in their 30s 20s 30s
through their 50s 60s but at the same
time tend to align with Democratic Party
politics and have gone along with the
more extreme versions the Democratic
Party politics we're seeing in recent
years so in my terminology
the deep state and others may call them
the shadow government because they're
affecting their own bureaucratic wishes
rather than the wishes of the people in
electing Donald Trump for instance and
Donald Trump of course is termed at the
swamp which is probably the term most
Americans immediately understand because
Washington was at one point a swath and
the the creatures coming out of the
swamp are certainly biting and fighting
back for their turf now I've worked in
DC about 22 plus years and I had a
different name for it I think I
developed the name in my head the
persistent bureaucracy and by that I
meant that even as administration's
changed and I thought certain tax and
policies would change it federal
agencies and so on I saw them stay the
same I saw the personnel stay the same
at that sort of mid-level range level is
that part of it yes and and it's great
honor to have you do the interview
because I've so tremendously admired
your work and I think your most recent
book smear really identifies many of the
same issues that I'm addressing although
mine is more in the context of Donald
Trump specifically but to your point in
terms of the persistence of the
bureaucracy and its determination to do
what it wants to do I've often said that
one of the great wrecking great you know
shocks for a president when they first
come into office is to realize how
little power they really have the
president gives an order an executive
order and the bureaucracy shows up and
says well mr. president I'm sorry but we
can't do that because here's this law
and this regulation and what you've
asked us to do is inconsistent with what
we're required to do by Congress and the
presidents have got to realize that it's
more than just making a decision or
writing an executive order to govern
when you have this massive and
entrenched bureaucracy which is
responsible for enforcing policy and
it's a shock as a president to find out
they're not on your mission
they're on their mission which may be
very the met you know directly opposed
diametrically opposed to what you ran on
it's a principle and I think Donald
Trump you know has had to find this out
even with the Republicans Reince Priebus
and the others who first came and said
oh you know we're the pros in Washington
will help you get Obamacare repealed and
replaced well once you relax you go
golfing we'll take care of this for you
well it didn't happen and President
Trump had to realize what presidents
like President Johnson have known coming
into the office how difficult it is the
give-and-take of passing legislation and
how much but bargaining there's got to
go on to get a piece of legislation
passed so President Trump fired
Reince Priebus and began saying that
team is out and then he went to his next
team which involved Wall Street and now
that team is out so I think president
Trump's learning lessons and realizing
increasingly that this deep state
entrenched the CIA and the FBI justice
really do intend to remove him from
office and when he realizes this he's
beginning to understand that he's had to
fight not only for his presidency but
for the Constitution and for the
Republic itself that's really what my
book is all about if you remember was
there a precise moment you can identify
that made you say to yourself there is a
deep state that were you starting to
believe there was a shadow government
well you know I suppose it goes all the
way back to the for me the assassination
of Jack Kennedy when I was 17 at the
time when that occurred when that
happened and certainly the first moments
that happened as a you know as a young
man had seen Jack Kennedy and been in
Washington and at hearings and the like
and it was a huge shock first that he
was assassinated and the way began to
find out how occurred this you know
gunfire shots
which seemed to be almost impossible to
happen then Lee Harvey Oswald gets shot
on that Sunday and I begin to say I
think I'm watching a play here this is a
drama being produced where we're not
supposed to know the real story behind
the scenes because the patsy has just
been killed and the Harvey Oswald said
he was a patsy and now he's silenced and
I began to think even at that moment
that you know this is a deep state that
Jack Kennedy did not control and I knew
he had been warned that the dangers were
significant because Jack Kennedy you
know understood when he gave his
American University speech for instance
declared his willingness to reach out
and work directly with the Russians that
that went against a lot of the generals
who he had come to realize during the
Cuban Missile Crisis Curtis LeMay and
others it's on tape you can hear it in
the archives really were half happy to
have war even if it was nuclear war and
so the idea that the deep state is not
only determined on policy and possibly
wanting an objective completely
different war with with Russia in that
period of time and willing to go to the
extent of engaging in an assassination
if they don't get what they want which
certainly did fundamentally change war
policy when Lyndon Johnson came in was a
recognition that you know the presidency
is constantly fighting with this deep
state CIA directed bureaucracy that is
capable of engaging in criminal acts
running drugs around the world
air America etc iran-contra the list
goes on but what I think people are
gonna find shocking when they read my
book is that really I'm able to document
a coup d'etat effort ongoing deeply
within the FBI
and the intention was to prevent Donald
Trump from being president
these holdovers from the Obama
administration deeply loyal to Hillary
Clinton but also to devise a means if
Donald Trump did win to make sure he
could quickly be removed from office and
that plan now I think is being being
increasingly documented and my book I
think will shock people when they
realized the extent to which that plan
has been a serious FBI Department of
Justice coup d'etat effort backed by the
CIA
what would you say not at this moment in
time but over the decades one in general
would you say is the goal of the deep
State
it's increasingly shifted to being
internationalist you know the CIA and
the people in Justice Department it
would take a look at John Brennan for
instance John Brennan had a deep history
with Obama his security firm actually
did the break-in that sanitized Obama's
passport records in 2008 during the
run-up to the that that year's election
cycle and he ends up national security
adviser and then he ends up in the CIA I
think it's highly possible he converted
to Islam some way along the way with his
career in the State Department
he's obviously demonstrated he speaks
Arabic and John Brennan made it a policy
within the CIA which was carried out
also in the Justice Department that for
instance the great number more Muslims
were brought into the administration and
the idea of radical Islamic terrorism
was ruled out this was more of an
internationalist view and it was a view
towards the kind of policy attitude you
see in the European Union that you would
see in the International Courts of
Justice like The Hague they would see in
the United Nations and I think these
policy wonks in the positions of power
and CIA and justice as well as in the
IRS we saw it as well had a
determination that conservatives were
equivalent to white supremacist and were
to be demeaned and not listened to
because the future was this new world
order in which we would go to a
globalism and internationalism beyond
the United States of America when
President Obama was fond of thinking
beyond America
what's the world beyond America well for
the Conservatives who you know are
patriots and I think it again the one
that the the startling points of my book
killing the deep state is the
recognition that there's this thick
division such that true patriots on the
conservative side want to preserve the
Constitution it isn't a it isn't a
racism it isn't a xenophobia I mean I
don't hate Islam I marched 200 miles
with you know after I wrote atomic Iran
in 2005 with the the Muslims who the
Iranians who were wanting freedom in
their country and almost everybody on
that March was Muslim so you know I've
argued that it's a complete as your book
points out smear on those of us who want
to have a conservative position that's
duly recognized as appropriate because
we're Patriots and that we're called
Sena phobes and all these other
deplorable --zz by Hillary Clinton shows
the division and I think that the this
deep state bureaucracy the coup d'etat
within the within the State Department
within the FBI and CIA within you know
this whole justice system reflects this
internationalism and we see it in and
infowars.com and Infowars where I'm you
know working as a Washington bureau
chief Washington correspondent
constantly we're under attack
as you know CNN attack well we can't
this is not legitimate this you know and
lying about what we do
port on lining even about lawsuits that
are filed or issues that are in the
sense I would call fake news but it
Infowars we're constantly under this
attack the smear attack because the hard
left does not want debate they want to
deal egde it amazed anyone who disagrees
with them especially with a patriot view
wanting to preserve the Constitution I
think one of the new things I saw over
time over the decades was in the past 10
years or so this trend toward not just
wanting to debate viewpoints and facts
but to censor them entirely which was
new to me when that first started
happening to me at CBS News when forces
didn't want to have their say in a piece
they simply didn't want a piece to air
they didn't want the public to hear
certain things which i think was you
know that struck me as strange well and
also I think this is one of the points
where you know we have a similar
experience that I've had you know
infowar is really where I'm proud to be
well why don't you give us a definition
of what is info wars.com occasionally a
piece crosses my desk from them they are
widely described as a conspiracy theory
website largely discredited every time
you read about it it says the
discredited info wars.com one and as
your book points out severe that's the
disinformation generated by people like
David Rock and Media Matters which
constantly leap on any appearance from
anyone have been for Wars and descends
on the publication to say how dare you
this is then they bring out the Southern
Poverty Law Center which of course you
know the the hard left today is engaging
in hate I'm being called the hate left
because it's so intolerant wants to
eliminate the First Amendment really not
interested in freedom of speech or
religion the hard left this hate left is
not interested in the Second Amendment
certainly don't want people to have a
right to bear arms as questioning the
4th amendment will be happy with all the
social media that are really just
serving as the front piece the you know
the desktop for the sea
and the NSA especially if we believe
Dennis Montgomery or ed Snowden or
Julian Assange with the massive amount
of intelligence is being gathered on the
American people completely
inappropriately and you at CBS I mean
we're fighting internally with stories
being repressed and the like and so we
at Infowars constantly bombard going
forwards I think is a one of the best
definitions I one of the investment
bankers looking at in four wars called
it very close to called it the most
disruptive news service opposing this
leftist hard left
mainstream media consensus which has
gotten to be kind of like a Pravda like
dissemination of corporate news only
what's approved news the the storyline
that the multinational corporations or
that the large entities or the Democrats
want advanced whereas for instance my
book killing the deep state is not going
to get I'm not going to get interviewed
by ABC or CBS or NBC they don't want
this story told so to be suppressed
now Infowars disruptively in a way where
I think Alex Jones had brilliantly been
able to challenge and threaten this
mainstream media consensus so much so
that they attack and smear it don't want
anyone even the cover it fought make
lies about lawsuits that are filed that
aren't filed yet disparage Alex Jones
when they have not really bothered to
listen with Alex Jones is deeply saying
these are this misrepresentation is
disinformation attack on Infowars I
think is calculated by Media Matters and
they've their annual fundraising efforts
document with pride how they've gotten
conservatives like Lou Dobbs fired or
how different people removed from their
networks because they attack the
advertisers and that
not only make up things about you I mean
if you read by WikiLeaks description you
know which I have given up trying
Wikipedia yeah you can't correct when
they something to be said on Wikipedia
the agenda editors can keep any truth or
facts that are contrary from being
published
why feel like Infowars were constantly
being attacked by wikipedia senators who
will dominate the agenda and demand that
we be called you know all these negative
smear words that they can event starting
with conspiracy theorists well if my
book pointing out that there's a coup
d'etat for dickens president Trump I
think the evidence for this is is
getting to be massive with that would be
a conspiracy theory except that it's a
conspiracy fact and that's the that's
the problem is the you can cover the
left wants to cover by controlling the
language controlling the dialogue they
want to basically call what they're
doing patriotic or in defense of the of
the one really they want to destroy the
Constitution they want to rewrite the
Constitution they want to be beyond
America that's the you know you take a
look at the hard left in California it
has nothing to do with what the
conservative rest of the country wants
and the higher left is not willing to
accept that they lost the election and
the majority of American people or at
least you know the majority of the
constitute of the electoral vote totals
did not by Hillary Clinton's argument
which was essentially a redo of the
media matters or George Soros funded
hard left line your book reads as
strongly supportive to me of the Trump
presidency he is not many people think
particularly conservative on many things
some things yes some things no changes
his mind from time to time were you
always a supporter of the Trump
presidency and how did that come about
I've known Donald trum for many years
going back to at least the 1980s when I
was I had a career in financial services
I was working internationally in
financial services and broadly in the
United States and for a couple years I
about lived at the Plaza Hotel and got
to know Donald Trump quite well and some
of the companies I was working with were
doing business with Donald Trump buying
the GM building across the street from
Plaza in New York was one example and I
always admired Donald Trump I always had
a great rapport with him and I thought
he was misrepresented such that he was
regarded you know if he knew him it was
really a very generous person who cared
deeply about his guests in the hotel
worked with the unions hired about every
race on the planet to work for him had
more women in his organization than than
Hillary Clinton ever hired in her
campaigns and was yet to mean but learn
how to live with it and I always said
Donald Trump always looks like he's
gonna lose just before he wins and he's
got a remarkable capability of winning
so I've been a Donald Trump supporter
and have watched him and when he began
to run for the presidency I was very
enthusiastic now again just like Alex
Jones Donald Trump is gonna be
disruptive gonna be a disruptive
presidency to this leftist agenda
because they don't want confrontation
they don't want the American people to
wake up or as you know they in the deep
Internet this red pilling and certainly
if you follow some of the things like
this queue and on which has been posting
on the deep chans which I've come I
pretty well identified as one of the
military intelligence working closely
with Trump that you know this is a
narrative that is again back to the fact
the the Constitution is going to be
preserved the Donald Trump is going to
turn the tide that he is weathered the
first attack the Mueller attempt a
special counselor to impeach Donald
Trump has failed and I'd say that
because you
all that Muller has is an indictment of
12 or 13 wacky Russians that posted some
things on the internet that even the
Department of Justice said did not
influence the election and Donald Trump
did not get involved with if that's it
that's all they've got or to concoct a
you know prosecution of general Flynn
for lying which I'm not sure he did I
mean this is the end of this first
attempt and it's failed I think now what
happens is Donald Trump launches the
counter-attack and we're in the initial
stages of that I expect it may take a
year or two years but before he's done
I'm convinced he will take seriously the
potential charges including treason
which I believe could be launched as
high as Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama
and I don't think President Trump will
hesitate to do that
can you briefly give me your highlights
of your educational background
you mentioned financial services in your
job history what are a couple bullet
points well I mean Mike my history was
pretty complex I've had different that's
I don't think anyone will ever fully put
together all the different things I've
done okay but I am Mike I was born in
Cleveland and I intended same asia's
high school and Case Western Reserve
then I went to Harvard
iver paid for me to get my PhD I had
written I think three books when I
applied as an undergraduate at Harvard I
got my PhD in 1972 I had done a lot of
writing at that time a work even on
racial violence and terrorism by the 80s
I had a top-secret clearance under a
contract with the State Department to
work on terrorism trained by some of the
top psychiatrists all over the world I
had a second large career in financial
services which I continued and worked
with insurance companies and with mutual
fund companies with banks all around the
world very strongly in the United States
and when I wrote co-authored with John
O'Neill unfit for command and the book
against Swift Boat
book against John Kerry at which Donald
Neil was really the hero of I
co-authored the book that gave me an
opportunity to begin another career
which I did working some 12 years with
Joseph Farah and worldnetdaily wnd.com
as a journalist and two years ago I
really began working with Alex Jones and
now I'm full-time as a Washington
correspondent with Infowars and very
pleased to be so you begin your book
with the smoking gun yes a smoking gun
well smoking gun is and this is one of
the critical piece of evidence that the
Inspector General has been releasing
from the Inspector General David
Horowitz the Justice Department and what
it involves is these two lovers which
are in the FBI Peter stroszek and Lisa
page and stroszek had a very top
position counterespionage head very
senior and they had some 10,000 emails
at the - or messages they exchanged some
of which have been released I mean
they're supposed to be lovers I'm not
sure they wrote so many instant messages
I don't know how they had time for a
love affair but at any rate when you
read them they're solidly anti from the
hate Trump this is the hate left they
hate Trump it's a disaster a catastrophe
they say to one another let me read this
little paragraph I say his name stroke I
don't know how to pronounce it but let's
say what struck the message makes clear
you wrote is that page and stroke in the
presence of a high-ranking FBI official
have laid out an insurance policy plan
to make sure Trump never served his term
as president
even if Trump pulled off a miracle to
win the election and beat stroke and
pages clear favorite Hillary Clinton
soon it developed that the insurance
policy involved the Russia collusion
evidence that the FBI had been quietly
accumulating against the Trump campaign
yes we'll see the this insurance policy
turns out I believe to be the the steel
dossier the fusion GPS dossier
now that originates it was originally
done by Republican
trying to oppose Trump in the primaries
and when it was clear Trump was beating
all these challengers which everyone
thought was going to be impossible the
the Hillary Clinton people picked up
this dossier and started funding it and
through the campaign also funding it of
course they laundered their payments
through Perkins Coie which also the law
firm that even defended Barack Obama the
law firm this this is a clearly partisan
law firm but that has worked with the
Democrats oh they launder the money and
none of this is as far as we know what
you're describing illegal this is legal
behavior
well I'd question I want I'm not an
attorney I question how they were paid
by the campaign now we get into the
would I think is clearly legality where
this fusion GPS is used to obtain the
FISA Court approval to do electronic
surveillance the FBI
yes it's advanced by the FBI and the
FISA Court is not explained and this
came out in the devin Nunez memo from
the House Intelligence Committee that
when that finds a court saw from the FBI
this fusion gps dossier advanced as
reasons to be in electronic surveillance
on Carter page a fairly peripheral
member of the Trump campaign at this
point I do not believe and we have not
yet seen the actual FISA Court arguments
our representations but from those who
have seen it it seems pretty clear that
the FISA Court was not told that the FBI
could not substantiate the claims could
not authenticate this dossier and the
dossier had an origin and opposition
research which would I think be to
material facts that might have convinced
the court not to grant the electronic
surveillance I and for the officers of
the court the FBI and whoever made the
arguments to the Weiser court not to
fully represent an act
form the document is a crime you well I
would also I documented with the help of
some FBI sources there's something
called woods procedures that were
developed actually under Muller when he
was head of the FBI to guarantee that no
fact that's presented to this face a
court can be an unverified fact and that
they're so precisely pinky about that
that if one fact is if he that they
can't verify on their own they go back
to the drawing board supposedly they're
not allowed to present anything
unverified to the court well in fact had
the whole purpose of the FISA Court is
to protect supposedly American citizens
from electronic surveillance because the
mandate of for instance of the NSA
National Security Agency is only to
conduct surveillance of foreigners now
what happens is as soon as the FISA
court approves Carter page then any one
kind of a page talks to becomes
collateral and those so for instance he
talks to Jeff sessions about Russia well
then now that's Jeff Sessions is now a
collateral person of interest and he is
under electronic surveillance without
necessarily going back to the FISA Court
to get permission so Carter page talks
to the whole group of everybody in the
campaign they're all under electronic
surveillance and Carter page was
involved in 2015 it turns out also with
the Russian kind of sting the Department
of Justice conducted and I continued to
question whether he is an undercover DOJ
agent himself which is not yet been
verified but it's certainly been
speculated now what happens then is a
wide number of people in the Trump
campaign are under electronic
surveillance this information comes into
the White House the White House unmasks
the names so it's no longer person a
person B person seed which was a
procedure again put in place
surveillance of US citizens is supposed
to be very rare if at all there are
instances and then when it happens they
said well we will mask the names even
side the government so nobody can use
them and then when
happens is it comes to yield the White
House and Valerie Jarrett begins
unmasking the names pians identifying by
name the person who are these people who
are under collateral electronic
surveillance and political enemies in
some cases in most cases and this
information gets released leaked to the
press now these are crimes and these are
high crimes if in fact the intent was to
deny Donald Trump either a legitimate
right to be a candidate or to produce
the evidence to impeach him because this
electronic surveillance was approved I
believe four times by the FISA Court and
it continued through the transition
Donald Trump's transition continued even
into the White House approved under
Donald Trump Donald Trump the Department
of Justice going in and getting approval
under Donald Trump to do this which I'm
sure you know was not an act that was
brought to Donald Trump's attention when
it was done I posed that question the
White House they didn't answer by the
way whether he knew you talk a lot about
the theory that the larger intelligence
community factors into the deep state I
think some of the best evidence
supporting the theory may have come on
March 17th when former CIA director John
Brennan issued a very over-the-top
emotional angry tweet to President Trump
here's what he said with the full extent
of your venality moral turpitude and
political corruption becomes known you
will take your rightful place as a
disgraced demagogue in the dustbin of
history you may scapegoat Andy McCabe
but you will not destroy America America
will triumph over you and then Obama's
former US ambassador to the United
Nations Samantha power she tweets that
out saying not a good idea to piss off
John Brennan which I I found pretty
astounding that former political
officials would be having this
threatening intimidating tone as if they
sort of lord over the public rather than
serving the public which is how I see
them well
these are exceptionally good points and
they'll be the brennan memo to me when I
read it falls in the category of you
know letters that you write and then as
soon as you've written it you ripped
them up and don't send them best advice
yeah you you know you got it out of your
system but you really don't want it to
go public now also it had the tendency
to mean the act as if he was already
still in the CIA that he could still
influence what the CIA was doing he does
maybe he died why you know this is the
questions it raises you know are the
people in the CIA listening wink wink to
what Brennan is telling them to do
are they undermining the presidency
these will become now legitimate
questions I mean at a minimum why John
Brennan thought he could take a stick
and poke it in the nose of the bear is
hard for me to comprehend well to the
unmasking is both Brennan and power have
acknowledged that extremely sensitive
controversial practice of unmasking
names of US citizens including political
enemies supposedly incidentally captured
during intelligence power at an
astonishing rate of almost daily during
the 2016 election and we see these are
you know the astonishing things that
okay to a little bit go to a slightly
different subject on the Hillary email I
was able to prove during the campaign
not only the Huma Abedin had access to
these emails but that she was sending
them to her yahoo.com account and some
of them released by Judicial Watch so
they had sensitive information and them
probably classified information that
could have been picked up by anybody who
she gave or sold or use her name in her
password now it turns out President
Obama had a pseudonym password or a
pseudonym email address that was not
Barack Obama that he used to communicate
over Hillary's private email server
while she was Secretary of State and out
of the country so I guess at justice
when they were looking at how they were
gonna cast commis statement which he was
rewritten by the way by my copic mccabe
and stroszek to officials in the FBI
they would have had to have is possibly
indicted Barack Obama for violation of
these same security requirements and
handling classes the original statement
said that Hillary Clinton had actually
emailed the president from Russia I
think it was on this unclassified write
system and they excise that from the but
it was statement you know president
Trump by President Obama responding with
the pseudonym so using his pseudonym to
go over the Clinton email server which I
think would be the specific violation so
when Comey does his statement to the
public and not only does he you know
there's Extro sukwon of the two lovers
and Andrew McCabe who has now been fired
at the recommendation of the Inspector
General and the public responsibilities
committee of the Department of Justice
for lying repeatedly under oath and
leaking information mccabe fired when
they rewrote commis statement during the
election they not only changed terms
like grossly negligent and her use of
classified material to extremely
careless which is not a legal definition
of the criminal act they also changed
that it was President Obama who had used
the server with the pseudonym email to
an official and government a top
official in government so the sanitizing
you know the the coup d'etat mean that
the shocking recognition this coup
d'etat was it not only in detail in
killing the deep state is it not only
involved an attempt to make sure the
donald trump lost the election or if he
did happen to win it that he would be
impeached it involved protecting hillary
clinton so she would not be indicted for
anything that she had done if FBI
director of the time James Comey was
against Trump why did he issue that
statement right before the election that
Hillary campaign blames for her loss in
some respects where he opened up the
email investigation into her again how
do you explain that well I do I it's
something that I've had
role in playing in that one but I was
reporting on whom Abba Dean's emails and
we were working too well figured out if
who Vava Dean was sending emails to her
yahoo account
she's probably also sending them through
to a computer that wasn't on the State
Department system so the suggestion was
how about Anthony Weiner's computer so
the New York Police Department had
several appeals at that period of time
saying why don't you go see once you go
get Anthony Weiner's laptop because he's
probably sexting to some underage girl
so how do we know well of course him
being this type of sexual criminal is
likely he was doing this once they
looked they together with certain of the
FBI officials in New York went and
seized the computer okay so now the NYPD
has the computer and what Comey realizes
is that the NYPD and this time we'll be
happy to release what they found on the
computer if Comey doesn't reinitiate the
investigation so one way or the other
the more damaging information could have
come out now I called up the New York
Police Department shortly after the
Komen made the other statement which
reversed that the you know it opened up
again for winners I've closed down again
within hours I called up the NYPD and
said where's the computer I said well
the Department of Justice from
Washington came in here and they took
everything they took the computer they
took all of our notes they told us we
were off of the case they took it all
back to Washington and then Comey made
his statement that the reopening had
been reclosed
so I think it was a he didn't have a
choice in that one because what he had
to go to town Loretta Lynch was either
we begin the investigation or you're
gonna read these things in the New York
papers what's actually on weiners
computer and I think that when that
material is made public I think it will
validate a lot of the claims you know
and the arguments that explain
well the shocking material I have in the
book you know it is with the killing of
the deep state I wrote the book to say
we've got to make sure we kill the deep
it's not just simply preserving Donald
Trump's election it's making sure that
we understand that we have rogue justice
system that's been politicized and
weaponized a rogue intelligence agencies
that have been politicized and
weaponized and they're now in Italy had
Hillary won would have been able to
affect all the censoring you know
Infowars would have been done censored
out immediately with no recourse I mean
already you've had you know Google
attempting to cancel my YouTube account
which they rescinded in you know 24
hours attacking Alex Jones you see the
difficulties that Facebook is now in
realizing it's sharing of information
for political campaigns compromise you
know I I take it like the sting song you
know instead of um every step you take
it's every click you make you know we
are watching you and that data go here
Eric Schmidt ends up being the one of
the chief technology outside advisors to
Hillary Clinton's campaign and all the
Google data is transferred to the
Clinton campaign to be used as their
get-out-the-vote effort that information
not shared with Donald Trump I don't
know they got permission from everybody
in Google to share this information it's
why I believe this probably in some
disclaimer that we don't read but we
give permission for that right we've
probably some you know 14 paragraph
disclaimer well this is why I think this
internet bill of rights is going to be
an increasingly important idea because
you can't have these corporate giants by
one legal paragraph somewhere stuck away
in a document nobody reads but everybody
has to agree to to use Google okay that
can't deprive you of your First
Amendment rights and that I think is
going to be a key issue that is the
coming battle I foresee being fought
out in the FTC the Federal Trade
Commission where I believe the real
regulation of the internet needs to be
and I'm predicting and killing the
estate and make the argument the these
internet giants have got to be regulated
they're going to have to be regulated
and we're gonna have to have our
fundamental rights incorporated into
these internet giants even if it
involves antitrust action to break them
up not to leave James Comey to quickly
write a lot about him in your book oh
yes do you think Trump would have been
better off not firing James Comey as FBI
director and befriending the deep State
or working with it rather than fighting
it would that have been possible it
wasn't possible and I think that you
know the only mistake Trump made was not
to fire James Comey immediately James
Comey was be happy to smile at Trump and
then go about you know sticking a knife
in his back
what Comey did is the same thing that
Andrew McCabe did they both wrote these
secret squirrel memos to themselves
documenting these meetings they had well
and even anybody with any experience in
the corporate world knows that these
self-serving memos written by you to the
file have limited probative value you're
probably doing your basic cya trying to
make the version you want of the most
favorable trying to make the other
person look bad
and by the way I don't think it's any
you know it's any accident
the commis book is going to be published
right on top of my book killing the deep
state so all the mainstream media you'll
get all the interviews from ABC New York
Times will fawn over the book he'll be
viewed as a martyr and a victim and he
will be portrayed as having a higher
honor which I believe is the title of
the book well none of them will dare to
interview me to look at killing the deep
state and that's why I think that it's
pretty remarkable the book has already
become number one in various categories
on Amazon and is one of the better
selling books maybe one of the best
selling books ever written on Donald
Trump and his presidency but it's going
to be constantly fought
by the mainstream media which does not
want you to hear what I wrote in killing
the deep state in that book you have
examples of call me and Muller the
Special Counsel Moeller and former FBI
director Comey working together in the
past on several projects one of them the
mark rich pardon
who is the billionaire oil trader
convicted of tax fraud and trading with
Iran during the Embassy hostage crisis
do you want to give an overview of that
well who I'm also a Bill Clinton pardon
a very the one that I really wanted the
point of including the story in this
story in the book well let me do the one
that's the it's worth started their
partnership started the one I think
there's couple that I think are really
significant I'm writing about them even
today one is that the role that Mueller
played when he was head of the FBI with
making sure the uranium one bribery
scandal which arm had been revealed by
William Campbell who is now a client
Victoria Townsend married to Joe to
Jennifer who is in fact now working with
the president we need to diagram this
out yes we did a diagram it out but the
point is Mueller I think played a
cover-up role there because had that
bribery scheme been known by the king of
the committee on foreign investment in
the United States that permission for
Russia's rose anthem their aid their
state-owned energy company to buy
uranium one get 20% of the US uranium
some of which by the way was shipped out
of the United States contrary to the
lies told at the time that permission
would never have been granted Hillary
Clinton you know Bill Clinton wouldn't
have gotten a $500,000 speed fee for one
speech the Clinton Foundation wouldn't
have gotten 145 million dollars in
contributions etc I believe the Hillary
Clinton people just put it out there
have said she had nothing to do oh yes
she didn't sit on the committee she was
didn't actually participate in the vote
that's that's absurd I mean first of all
everybody had a brain
knew what was going on and that Hillary
Clinton said oh I won't sit on this one
but the person that she appointed as her
surrogate was somebody who had a vested
interest in pleasing her
okay now the HSBC it's a bank yes the
Hong Kong Bank a bank which was
laundering money billions of dollars for
drug criminals and for international
terrorists I help [ __ ] John Cruz a
banker from Long Island came to me with
a thousand pages that he'd walked out of
the bank with trying to blow the whistle
I started publishing in my banking
experience this was clear evidence of
money laundering always in contacted by
partner Homeland Security permanent
Senate investigating committee had
ultimately ended up with 1.9 billion
dollar fine being paid by HSBC Comey was
on the board of HSBC when this happened
so not yet FBI director he was sitting
on the board of this bank that was
accused precisely and as a board had
responsibility over the bank's
activities which it should have included
figuring out there was money laundering
going on Mueller was head of the FBI
Loretta Lynch was the US attorney who
negotiated nobody goes to prison okay
now on this kind of these people working
together which is a long-term
relationship making sure things are
covered up you know it's impossible that
the Comptroller of the currency if I
found out from a thousand pages John
Kruse had that he brought to me out of
lost loved the Long Island branches and
he wouldn't be listened to he'd tried to
talk to all these people they didn't
want to hear at a Department of Homeland
Security Comptroller currency can see
the money laundering going on it should
be known by the intelligence agencies
you can't run the drug industry without
the intelligence agencies being involved
and this cast of characters were the
cover-up artists may I read a brief
section about that that I marked sure
you wrote by allowing the bank HSBC to
avoid criminal charges despite pleading
guilty to money laundering violations
for both a Mexican drug cartel and
Mideast radical Islamic terrorist groups
Comey
Muller Lynch and then Attorney General
Eric Holder were all playing major roles
as deep state operatives and then I'm
skipping ahead serving on the HSBC the
bank board was not commis only chance to
cash in on his faithful service to the
deep State in his various FBI and DOJ
assignments you write from 2005 to 2010
before serving on that Bank board Comey
served as general counsel and senior
vice president for Lockheed Martin a
major US military contractor jobs for
which Comey earns six million dollars
right those pay off and by the way we
you know WikiLeaks pointed out that call
me when I believe in this 2009 trip to
Russia where Hillary had Mueller Mueller
went on this trip had Robert Mueller
head of the FBI travel to Russia with
some uranium samples that supposedly
were from a heist as theft in you know
East Germany but the point was what was
Mueller doing on that trip what was that
little uranium visit to Russia all about
by Mueller in 2009 for Hillary Clinton
and why did it take wikileaks to reveal
it from State Department cables that
WikiLeaks got ahold of when these deep
state operatives again have ties that I
think in my book are shocking it's
shocking to see the extent to which
Soros Hillary Clinton Barack Obama and
including down to the operatives Robert
Mueller etc have all been working
together over the years on various
projects
is there any plus side to the notion of
a deep state and by that I mean the
notion that no single President or
administration Democrat Republican or
otherwise could do that much to
drastically change or hurt the country
well I'm gonna go back to what John
Kennedy said he said he should break up
the CIA into a thousand pieces and he
replaced Allen Dulles as the head of the
CIA the mistake John Kennedy made was
not to do it that day and if you've got
a rogue apparatus and the CIA John
IRS it's no surprise that Tea Party
activists couldn't get their 501 C 3 & 4
applications approved through Lois
Lerner it's no it's no surprise that all
of the political ization of the
Department of Justice was aimed I
believe to the detriment of law
enforcement Joe Arpaio being pardon Tom
Perez a dogged ly went after Joe Arpaio
for criminal violations of a in court of
order to impose set of rules in maricopa
county sheriff's office and that had to
do with anti-discrimination in car stops
of hispanics and you know president
Trump pardoned our pile as Tom Perez now
one of the LaRosa lawyer history the
leader of the Democratic National
Committee this is the hard nature of
these political eyes organizations I
can't see any benefit to a weaponized
politicized partisan CIA
IRS DOJ FBI named them all the alphabet
industries I you know I think the
President Trump
frustrations in dealing with this are
apparent when he says let's just tear
down the FBI building and start all over
again a couple of questions we don't
have a lot of time left I want to get
through to kill the deep state you said
Donald J Trump must defeat Robert
Moeller's plan to remove him from office
one way or the other you want to
elaborate on that what else do you think
Donald Trump needs well I think that's
clear I think that the this
investigation is I said has come to an
end
Mueller is out of gas he's now fishing I
think that's where he's at and the
putting it to an end the clearest way
and I recommend it in articles that I've
been writing and in the book is to get
Muller himself under criminal
investigation let's get an honest grand
jury that investigates uranium one and
targets and subpoenas Robert Mueller and
gets him to produce all of his documents
from the uranium one bribery
investigation at that point when he's
the investigative target of a grand jury
legitimately called in the Department of
Justice
I believe Mueller resigns is there
anything Trump should have done
differently in terms of besides acting
more quickly and in your terms to get
rid of Comey perhaps or something like
that it's he responsible for making
things so hard on himself
there's nothing Trump can do that the
mainstream media these operatives this
as I say media matters motivated group
Soros funded behind the scenes to
Schmidt the smeared Trump orders Russian
salad dressing for lunch it's going to
be evidence he's conspiring with Putin
there's nothing he can do and no matter
what speech he gives or what had the
press oh yeah I had press credentials to
travel with Romney's campaign
presidential campaign presidential
campaign the last three weeks in 2012
and the the job of the mainstream media
press wasn't to cover Romney's speech on
economics it was asked gotcha questions
about abortion or anything they get a
headline on and flying around joke with
each other about who did the best gotcha
article that made Romney look like a
jerk that was their whole game when
you're dealing with the deep state it is
in us vocal farm is the mainstream media
and their job with they're all you know
giggling with each other about that they
accomplish is to make you look bad
Donald Trump is right and targeting that
this it's why my book is killing the
deep state this has got to be put to an
end and it'll life may not realize it
left things will we'll have this
identity politics socialists
european-style
communist you know utopia once we could
end the First Amendment and once we can
politicize the entire government to go
against conservatives make sure no
conservative is ever allowed on social
media no info wars is existing everybody
has lawsuits they're all put in prison
or sent to thought reform camp so it'll
be really a wonderful world well they
never realized that a deep stake and
turn on them to we should not have a
politicized weaponized
rock Rossio we do is time to radically
you know even with this SES the Carter
sign this special system protecting some
10,000 bureaucrats from being fired
because their senior managers up just
closed the department's maybe we start
should start dealing with the
bureaucracy not by firing bureaucrats
but by closing agencies to those who
won't read the book perhaps and say
you're just a conspiracy theorist with a
bunch of ridiculous conspiracy theories
what do you say well I mean it's severe
detriment that they're not good thing I
they not gonna look at the twenty pages
of footnotes they're not gonna go look
at the documented evidence and I think
what's happening is that the narrative
is changing because as I point out Trump
is fighting a propaganda attack here so
he says there's no rushing cool evidence
really says we just have to look harder
the way they will defeat the propaganda
is to undermine those advancing it we
realize the crimes committed by McCabe
the lying the lying under oath the
leaking of information which may go all
the way up to the Obama White House with
leaking information from the electronic
surveillance of the FISA Court unmasking
names and leaking these are crimes over
the American people understand crimes
were committed and see them these two
lovers Stroh's they can page their
10,000 instant messages are I open errs
and the American people are ready to
understand a whole different scene than
the mainstream media has presented them
one word one phrase is the deep state
win or does Donald Trump win Donald
Trump wins it's a pleasure thank you